[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are learning about a type of health
insurance that can lead to unexpected
medical debt and speaking of debt a
hundred million people in America are
saddled with Health Care debt according
to a kff study and that includes Believe
It or Not people with health insurance
our series medical price roulette looks
at how one Tennessee family potentially
faced hundreds of thousands of dollars
in medical bills even though they
thought they were covered by their
insurance plan consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner has their
story Anna good morning Good morning
Tony yes so let's say you have a job
that comes with a health insurance plan
and your family's doctors are in the
plans network but suddenly in an
emergency maybe they're not that was the
scenario faced by one family in
Chattanooga
53 year old Joe Smith is a father of
four and a runner seemed perfectly
healthy his wife Stacy Says until one
night in February at the dinner table he
was saying things that weren't making
sense not putting information together
properly at the emergency room she says
doctors could find no clear cause for
his symptoms but would a CT scan did
find a brain aneurysm as soon as they
said the words brain aneurysm I mean
that's terrifying I just knew that if
you had one that it's usually something
that ruptures in you you don't make it
put in there within days a neurosurgeon
confirmed Joe would need surgery as soon
as possible to prevent a
life-threatening rupture we knew that he
kind of had this ticking time bomb in
his head the surgery was scheduled for a
Monday in March but the Friday before
the doctor's office called the surgery
had to be canceled because the Smith's
health insurance company was refusing to
pay for it why the denial Joe's health
insurance through his job Blue Cross
Blue Shield of Illinois said that local
neurosurgeon Dr May shanghaiasi who
specialized in brain aneurysm was out of
network and the Smith's health insurance
provides no coverage for out-of-network
doctors and hospitals the insurer calls
it a high performance Network or hpn but
they're generally called closed networks
with cheaper premiums for employers and
employees but zero out of network
options Georgetown University Professor
Sabrina corlett studies health insurance
reform some employers are increasingly
introducing these closed Network plans
or narrow Network plans as a way to cut
back on their health care costs so Stacy
Smith went looking for another
neurosurgeon anywhere near their home in
Chattanooga Tennessee who was in that
hpn Network and could perform the
surgery she couldn't find a single one I
spent all day Monday I think in tears on
the phone with anybody who would listen
to me at the insurance company saying
look he needs the surgery now what do we
do and what'd they tell you I'm sorry
there's no policy there is no protocol
there's no plan I mean you were staring
down the bear girl essentially right
yeah it was very scary
what was the greatest fear that he
wouldn't survive
that it would rupture before
before we could get the surgery the day
after the canceled surgery the couple
say Joe developed a persistent headache
and went to the ER the next day Dr giasi
performed emergency surgery how lucky is
he that this was even caught before the
aneurysm ruptured yeah extremely lucky
there's a lot of the people in this
country that don't have that that luck
and they are not treated in the manner
that he was but when we sat down with
them two weeks after the surgery the
couple still didn't know whether the
bill possibly hundreds of thousands of
dollars would be covered is the
insurance company going to pay for that
or not we don't know nearly a month
after the surgery and after we contacted
the company Blue Cross Blue Shield of
Illinois sent the Smiths this letter
saying their request for Dr gyasi to
perform surgery had been denied an error
and it would now be approved the company
later told us it couldn't comment on Joe
Smith's case but said in some situations
where an in-network provider is not
available a member may receive services
from an out of network provider and this
speaks for to the need for some basic
standards for you know how quickly a
plan has to review and act on a request
for authorizing this kind of a service
but right now
um unfortunately you know a lot of these
insurance companies think that they can
save some money by dragging their feet
in a spanner in fact we found that in
March the same month Joe Smith was
waiting for his surgery the state of
Illinois fined Blue Cross Blue Shield of
Illinois over six hundred thousand
dollars for violating state laws
including failing to properly apply
maximum driving time and distance
standards to reflect the actual number
of providers available the insurance
company told us it's committed to
helping our members access the care they
need where and when they need it but Joe
Smith says I don't like them having that
kind of power over people's lives that
you know they should and mess around
people's lives and you know push it off
push it off deny deny do you feel like
the insurance company put your husband's
life at risk yes absolutely
absolutely
well Joe Smith recovered from surgery
he's back working full-time in his job
as an appliance and air conditioner
repairman beyond the hospital costs The
Smiths were worried about follow-up care
all of which is now expected to be
billed as in networks which means it'll
be covered covered we think right that's
what they're now being told yeah but
imagine the predicament they're in they
need the surgery and you're told nope
it's not covered so sorry nothing we can
do that just makes no sense right and
she's spent and you've been paying all
the money for the insurance yeah and she
spent hours and hours on the phone
talking to one person after another
we've all done this right yes you call
they transfer to somebody else you call
again and you're on hold
and you know meanwhile trying not to
stress her husband out because she's
worried this thing will rupture we
believe that this is going to create
change for the better when it comes to
these insurance I did in this one case
it would appear yeah I mean you would I
mean
I mean tumors right because they checked
check to make sure their doctors were in
but then something unexpected heavens
and in that situation can you control
what will happen unfortunately in many
situations you're not in control and
then you wind up you know rolling with
whatever also Anna on the phone just
trying to find a random Doctor Who could
do this as opposed to a doctor that you
know and you're familiar with his skills
anybody can anybody do this surgery
that's not right either right about that
Anna thank you so much